hi I'm Maddy Wozniak and I'm a junior
studying computer science and my project
is I've been looking at a data set
called data warehouse connect to try to
use it to optimize oxygen delivery to
the preterm infant and so it's the
motivation behind this is it's important
to keep preterm infants within a set
oxygen range because if their oxygen
dips too low it's called hypoxemia which
causes mortality and if it's too high
it's called hyperoxia and causes
morbidity and so we have this data set
called data warehouse connect and it
provides quasi real-time data including
alarm strength physiological waveforms
spo2 data access for all the patients in
the NICU at Beth Israel Deaconess
Medical Center and so we sampled this
data set to get patients that are
preterm which is less than 37 weeks and
also in the hospital for more than 24
hours and so this led to 367 patients
and so we looked at the oxygen
saturation for these 367 patients they
determined that the coverage that we had
and so we found on average we have 96%
data coverage for these patients and so
this means from the time of admission to
the time of discharge we have
second-by-second oxygen saturation
information for 96% of the patients day
and so this leads to about 8,000 patient
days of Auctions data showing that this
is a very rich data set and so when we
dive a little bit more deeper into the
oxygen saturation of the patients we
group the patient's by gestational age
and by birth wait to see how these two
factors affected the percent time that
they spend outside of their target
oxygen saturation range and so we found
patterns that you would expect to see so
we found that the most premature
patients and also the patients with the
lowest birth weight were the most likely
to leave their target oxygen saturation
range thank you